le droit
les huit ans aux professionnels du
danemark de norvège d'italie ou du
portugal ont participé au stage dans ces
environnements
pendant quinze jours ils ont découvert
besançon et s'en sont inspirés pour moi
parce que c'est un à droite un à droite
vieux et c'est un petit peu hills où les
il n'y a pas beaucoup des personnes qui
vient mais les personnes qui vient l'est
où la poubelle sur 15 ha il laissa ici
et ça me donne quelque chose c'est que
comme il fait ses études au lycée avant
mais pas maintenant j aime ça s'ils
aiment ça allait trop vite comme un
petit lieu secret
encadré de chorégraphes comme wright
grands romanciers des pièces de saintes
est venu dans les décors naturels les
vidéos de ses chorégraphies seront
présentés au festival de montbéliard le
24 septembre prochain